up next christopher moran explores the
similarities between ian fleming's james
bond novels and the real world of the
central intelligence agency this lecture
at the library of congress is the
subject of mrs moran's forthcoming book
classified secrecy and the state in
post-war britain
it's an hour 10 minutes
all right can you hear me in the back
there betty
okay
um my name is mary louise rieker and i
want to welcome you today on behalf of
the library of congress's
office of scholarly programs and the
john w kluge center to a lecture by dr
christopher moran
entitled in fleming
james bond and the public perception of
the central intelligence agency
first i want to request that you make
sure your telephones are off
so we don't get ringing in the midst of
the taping
dr christopher moran is a postdoctoral
research assistant in the department of
politics and international studies at
the university of warwick england
at warwick he is attached to a large
arts and humanities research council
project titled landscapes of secrecy
headed by professor richard aldrich
which examines the creation of the
public record of the cia
in realms such as history
memoirs
novels
and film
dr moran's 2008 doctoral thesis which
took a fresh look at britain's culture
of secrecy
with a particular focus on press
censorship and official memoir writers
is forthcoming this year is a monograph
published by cambridge university press
entitled classified
secrecy and the state in post-war
britain
and since 2 december of 2008 dr moran
has been researching and writing a book
on c i a memoirs and i'm sure you'll
hear something about that today
dr moran has had articles either in
print or accepted for publication in
journals such as intelligence and
national security
studies and intelligence
the international journal of
intelligence and
and the journal of cold war studies
he has also edited a collection of
essays titled spooked
britain empire and intelligence since
1945
published by cambridge scholars
publishing
and he recently contracted a second
edited volume on the development of
intelligence historiography
which he is co-editing with dr
christopher murphy the working title for
that volume is writing intelligence
history
and it is to be published by edinboro
university press
dr moran is also co-editing the oxford
handbook of the cia for oxford
university press and i want you please
to help me welcome him today dr
christopher moran
there thank you ever so much for the uh
the kind words of introduction mary lou
that is uh most appreciated
in recent years significant attention
has been devoted to the role of the
central intelligence agency in the
cultural cold war there is emerging
consensus that by the 1950s the cia was
expending considerable resources
attempting to influence cultural
production with the objective of
broadening the west's struggle against
communism
historical analysis of this subject is
perhaps most synonymous with francis
stoner saunders's controversial account
who paid the piper which revealed the
scale of the agency's secret links with
a host of elite cultural figures
including artists musicians journalists
and intellectuals
who paid the piper charted the cia's
funding of apparently independent
institutions including the paris-based
congress for cultural freedom
it is striking however that whereas the
subject of the cia's cultural
investments has produced a significant
oracle literature little thought has
been given to the issue of
representation
specifically the question of how the cia
itself has been portrayed in culture
the cia's cultural cold war is a very
different field of inquiry than the cia
in cold war culture
the cultural cold war refers to cultural
conflict between the blocks with a
particular focus on attempts by the
state to use high culture as an
instrument of political persuasion
the notion of cold war culture by
contrast has a more anthropological
meaning
necessarily more vague than the cultural
cold war it is concerned less with
semi-official cultural policy as
articulated by groups such as the
congress for cultural freedom than with
the expansion of an autonomous culture
industry derived from popular literature
music and films
so why should we as historians as
scholars as members of the public be
interested in depictions of the cia in
the popular culture of the cold war
what's the value added here why is this
important and i think the answer to this
question stems from the agency's passion
especially during its early years for
secrecy
until the mid 1970s when congressional
inquiries and investigative journalism
exposed some of the agencies most
disreputable if not outright illegal
activities the cia was an extremely
secret organization
its employees were instructed not to
reveal the nature of their employment
even to officials in other branches of
u.s government
journalists many of whom were cautious
of challenging the national security
paradigm that existed in the 1950s
seldom probed into agency business
lecturing at santa clara university in
1976 retired cia director william colby
spoke at length about just how secretive
the agency was during the early days of
the cold war it was all secret he
emphasized we weren't allowed to say
anything about it and we pretended that
it didn't exist
according to colby when the agency
discovered that pilots approaching the
potomac river on route to washington d.c
we're telling passengers to look out of
their window to take a view of cia
headquarters at langley there followed a
wave of sackings in the airline industry
as a result of secrecy popular culture
found itself in a unique and privileged
position with neither the agency itself
nor journalists willing to talk about
the cia at least until the 1970s culture
had the opportunity to fill a vacuum and
fill that vacuum it did
the mid to late 1960s in particular
witnessed an outpouring of cultural
renderings of the agency from the 1965
film operation cia which i confess i
haven't seen to the successful spoof
television series get smart
now this is not to contend that popular
culture necessarily railroaded public
understandings of the cia it is arguing
rather that by failing to open up about
its activities the cia indirectly
allowed the culture industry to write
the first draft of its history
it is arguing that when historians
consider the genesis and evolution of
cia historiography more attention should
be paid to the proto history as it was
established by popular culture
this lecture should like to analyze how
the agency was represented in one
cultural creation the james bond novels
of british fiction writer ian fleming
many of double o seven's operations were
carried out in concert with cia staff
most notably felix leiter who appeared
in no less than six of bond's 14
literary outings
the books which by 1964 had sold 79
million copies worldwide so these things
were widely read very very popular offer
i think a particularly important case
study
the key reason for studying bond as
opposed to other spy fiction stories
from the era is that the novels were for
a long time and this is quite remarkable
as far as i can tell the only cultural
products to discuss the cia directly and
even to refer to the agency by its real
name
in the 1950s although american culture
was awash with espionage the focus
tended to be on homeland subversives the
fbi rather than international spies
operating overseas
in the early to mid 1960s when writers
and filmmakers finally did shift their
attention away from domestic espionage
to consider overseas intelligence
organizations there was a great deal of
tip-toeing around the subject of the
agency fearful of retributions from the
u.s government at whose whim they were
able to operate
famously alfred hitchcock was required
by the legal department at universal
actually this is not particularly well
known this is a little archival finding
here at the library of congress but
alfred hitchcock was required by the
legal department at universal to change
the title of his classic spy yarn
starring carrie grant from the cia's
story to north by north west which came
out in 1959
as a briton however
fleming was able to buck the trend
publishing his accounts outside of the
jurisdiction of u.s controls he could
pretty much say what he liked about the
agency and it was not until the mid to
late 1960s when deference to government
agencies began to crumble against the
backdrop of the vietnam war that the u.s
popular culture in the round would
follow the fleming formula and discuss
the cia unencumbered
so in this lecture
i should like to put forward several
arguments
carefully analyze the cia that emerges
from the 07 books is complex
multifaceted and constantly evolving
in fleming's hands the cia is shown to
be a force for good in a dangerous world
no mention is made of intelligence
failures nor is there any discussion of
dirty tricks
i will argue that fleming's depiction of
cia officers as right-serving loyal and
decisive patriots was to a large extent
a reflection of femi fleming's genuine
fondness for the u.s intelligence
community it derived from his positive
experience of working alongside american
spies during the second world war when
fleming had worked in the area of
anglo-us intelligence liaison and
crucially was fortified by a remarkable
post-war friendship with cia director
alan dulles the later bomb novels in
particular offer a conspicuously
deferential treatment of the agency and
this was quite deliberate on fleming's
part and coincided with the period when
his acquaintance with dulles was at its
peak and when the latter amazingly was
asking fleming's views and advice on the
pressing intelligence concerns of the
day
i'll also show that in the novels the
cia is shown to work in perfect harmony
with british allies
as fleming described it the cia's
relations with mi6 the british secret
intelligence service transcended purely
immediate strategic considerations and
was cemented by mutual values shared
ideals and a sense of kinship and this
portrayal is really symptomatic of what
scholars now refer to as the evangelical
approach to anglo-us relations which
posits that there's a an indefinable
bond of trust and cooperation between
britons like myself and the united
states
in this lecture though i should like to
argue that in presenting relations
through the evangelical prism fleming
provided his readers with a slightly
airbrushed picture of the cia's
relationship with mi6 in real life the
relationship was often mired in distrust
and suspicion instead of feeling
culturally bound to mi6 officers many in
the cia regarded them as class conscious
snobs who gloried in pomp titles and the
material accoutrements of wealth
and i guess the final argument that i'd
like to make is that despite being
generally positive about the cia fleming
is nonetheless extremely careful not to
have the agency steel bonds thunder
although lighter extracts double 07 from
numerous difficult situations even
saving his neck on several occasions it
is unquestionably mi6 who is at the
front line of the intelligence cold war
a recurring theme is that lighter the
agency provides the technical support
money
and added muscle when required but bond
has the superior tradecraft
in casting the cia in the role of junior
partner in the anglo-american
intelligence alliance will finally argue
that fleming flattered his readers with
fantasy for in real life it was the
agency who was top dog
so to my first um sort of substantive
subsection which i've called filling a
vacuum so the publication of the first
bond novel casino royale in spring 1953
really did introduce readers to an
organization in the shape of the cia
which was barely known about by the
public
created in 1947 the agency maintained a
policy of disclosing nothing about its
activities its staffing roles were
classified much of its budget was
concealed in other appropriations it was
not even listed in the washington
telephone directory
in this period the media seldom broke
stories about the cia
journalists exhibited a remarkable
deference to government-defined
parameters of national security
and i think accepted the prevailing
consensus about the need to keep
intelligence affairs secret
in 1954 for example arthur salzberger
publisher of the new york times agreed
to the cia's request that the newspaper
pull an overly inquisitive reporter out
of guatemala so that the agency's secret
operations there would not be exposed
casinos real
royals publication also came at a time
when books about the cia were in short
supply now unlike today when monographs
popular histories and memoirs about the
agency roll off the press at an
incredible rate back then in the 1950s
cia historiography was practically
non-existent
the first best-selling comprehensive
history the invisible government by
journalist david wise and thomas ross
did not appear until 1963.
indeed so disturbed was the agency by
the notion that someone had finally
dared to write an authoritative account
officials seriously considered buying up
all 20 000 copies before they reached
bookshops
but of course when when casino royale uh
was published moreover there was no
competing narratives from popular
culture at this time
films and television shows that dealt
explicitly with the agency were
conspicuous by their absence
until the mid to late 1960s a period
when agency activity started to trickle
into the newspapers films and television
networks were required to seek
permission from the cia to use its brand
but permission was never forthcoming and
in hollywood it was an open secret that
the agency disapproved of filmic
treatments of its activities
in february 1962 another little nugget
from the collections here at the uh the
library of congress february 1952 a
senior figure in warner brothers was
given extremely short shrift by the cia
when he pitched them the idea of the
agency giving the studio technical
assistance in the making of a
forthcoming spy movie it was put to him
in no uncertain terms that the agency
quote would not only be unable to afford
such guidance but that we the cia would
take every step to discourage the
production of a movie which purported to
represent current u.s espionage unquote
and for more than a decade no one in
tinseltown was really prepared to
challenge this and make cia movies and i
think this is for several reasons
firstly in the 1950s a large portion of
the motion picture industry was was
literally scared stiff of federal
government agencies brought about by the
wave of sackings black listings and
prosecutions that accompanied the
investigations carried out by the house
of un-american activities committee
a second possibility as francis stoner
saunders has shown is that well many of
hollywood's power players from this era
people like howard hughes the filmmaker
john ford daryl f zanak head of 20th
century fox had sort of been recruited a
little bit very informally by the cia as
part of a sort of ad hoc consortium
designed to influence the production of
commercial films so accordingly there
was no real pressure from the top of the
movie industry to film and be damned
and finally i think hollywood in the 50s
was was pretty much people by
scores of intensely patriotic
individuals the type of individuals who
didn't need telling about the types of
subjects that were not fit for the big
screen
so against this background the bond
novels helped to fill a remarkable
public vacuum by default i think fleming
was the first person to give the cia a
cultural public identity the early
public profile of the agency was in
effect his creation through his writings
millions of people would learn about the
agency
for the first time
to my second section which i've called
shared ideals and collegiality
and this really seeks to address several
interrogatives and questions
how was the cia depicted in bond
moreover what was the inspiration for
this portrayal and how accurate was it
well the agency as i said made its debut
in double 07's first adventure casino
royale a tortelle of a soviet-backed
trade union paymaster who organizes a
high-stakes bacharach game in an attempt
to recover union money lost in a failed
chain of brothels
in the novel the cia is presented as a
first-rate spy service with close
cultural ties to mi6 in the shape of
felix lighter it possessed according to
fleming quote a cool resourceful and
fearless patriot unquote
when lighter and bond first meet fleming
paints a scene where both men are
perfectly at ease with each other's
company both understand that their
respected services have secret interests
that are above those of mere
transatlantic
alliance politics indeed according to
fleming the two men share an intuitive
connection
lighter looked at bond and read his mind
and the attachment between lighter and
bomb that we see here is highly relevant
of this evangelical approach to anglo-us
relations that i was talking about
now fleming later admitted that lighter
had been modeled on this gentleman here
general william j donovan wartime head
of the office of strategic services the
forerunner to the cia as personal
assistant to the director of british
naval intelligence during the second
world war donovan had worked
fleming rather had worked closely with
donovan on a number of projects a warm
anglophile donovan was captivated by
fleming's high spirits lively tongue and
unorthodox methods seeing him as an
exemplar of the swashbuckling and
slightly eccentric british secret
service tradition
on his official trips to the united
states for example fleming would always
carry a commando fighting knife and a
fountain pen loaded with a cyanide
capsule i did try to bring these items
for you but they were confiscated at
dulles in international airport
is often claimed that fleming at
donovan's request even wrote the
blueprint for the formation of the cia
according to admiral john godfrey head
of british naval intelligence fleming
carried out this task dutifully and
received from donovan a 0.38 cult
revolver inscribed with the words for
special services
in casino royale mi6 is unquestionably
the dominant authority in the
anglo-american intelligence relationship
leiter's mission is that of official
backup washington's pretty sick we're
not running the show he laments to bond
anyway i'm under your orders and i'm to
give you any help you ask for
assuming the role of serving lieutenant
at the beck and call of bond lighter
performs relatively pedestrian important
but pedestrian tasks such as disposing
of dead bodies and completing the
necessary paperwork for back home
fleming's interpretation of the mi6 cia
power balance was very much at odds with
developments at this time in the real
world at the time of casino royale's
publication britain had liquidated many
of her imperial holdings including the
jewel in the crown india and was
increasingly struggling with problems in
the middle east and africa and britain's
humbling
global contraction was accompanied by
domestic problems including unemployment
and inflation so against this background
britain had actually become ever more
reliant upon u.s support
now fleming's largely positive portrayal
of anglo-american intelligence i would
argue is pretty unsurprising during the
second world war fleming had witnessed
first-hand the work of the british
security coordination in new york a
cover organization set up by mi6 to gain
the sympathies of the american public
headed by canadian industrialist william
stevenson the british security
coordination really is one of the wars
great success stories characterized by
an outstanding degree of collegiality
between british intelligence officers
and their american equivalents
writing for the sunday times in 1962
fleming teasingly referred to the bond
books as autobiography claiming that 007
had been modeled on british and american
agents he had seen working together
under stevenson
in the post-war era fleming's
unqualified vision of benign
anglo-american intelligence relations
was certainly flawed many people in the
cia saw mi6 officers as sort of sort of
slightly deluded toffs desperately
clinging to the antiquated values of
empire in a drastically changed world
according to former cia officer joseph
burkholder smith the british were seen
as quote a bunch of supercilious snobs
towards whom the attitude was don't tell
the bastards anything unquote oh yeah i
hope you don't think i think that of me
cia alumnus chester cooper who did a
tour of duty of london in the 1950s
claimed in his memoir that he had never
felt comfortable in the company of mi6
officers on account of their somewhat
peculiar
stuffy class orientated customs and
indeed his first encounter with the
british had left him feeling slightly
alienated and inadequate and this is uh
this is cooper here he says i found
myself sitting between two giants
wearing identical black suits savile row
that's a very posh british tailor
identical blue stripe ties eaton very
posh school an identical spectacles
the man on my right passed a paper to
the one on my left it looked like
something from sanskrit vedas i later
found out that this was greek pentameter
a chap stuck his head around the door
and bellowed south africa 14 for three
all groaned i made a surreptitious note
in the event that this was code for some
crisis in commonwealth affairs cricket
test match you know someone shouted to
me all laughed i smiled weakly
in real life the cia had other reasons
to be mistrustful of mi6 in may 1951 the
dramatic flight to russia of gentleman
sky a gentleman spies guy burgess and
donald mclean provoked a real sort of
peroxism of anger within the cia
cia chiefs were mortified by the double
defection mclean's treachery in
particular was seen as particularly
damaging since he had served in the
british embassy in washington dc and
have been entrusted with details of
anglo-us nuclear policy and cia concern
actually in the 1950s about british
security had led them at several points
to become quite cheery and nervous about
sharing intelligence secrets and
remarkably mi6 was sometimes denied
access to information derived from the
cia's u2 program despite providing some
of the pilots
to my uh to my third uh subsection now
which i've called nobody does it better
although the bond novels of the 1950s
were unquestionably appreciative of the
cia's role in the anglo-american
intelligence alliance readers are left
in no doubt that when it came to the
great game of espionage mi6 was by far
the superior outfit
in fleming's universe mi6 was never
cash-strapped or under-resourced and its
officers were plucky intelligent and
multilingual
in live and let die for example lighter
comes across as a little bit of a sort
of second-rate gatherer of intelligence
unable to blend in with the locals and
ultimately forced to rely on paid
informants in contrast bond excels he
gets his information by befriending
natives
and by seducing the villains mistress
solitaire and like many of the
improbable women in the series solitaire
is just unable to stop herself leaking
secrets during pillow talk
without bond looking out for him lighter
is shown to be a bit of a bungler his
decision to reconnoit him mr big the
enemy mr biggs florida headquarters
unaided on his own is a disastrous one
since he is apprehended beaten up and
then fed to the villain's pet shark an
encounter which leaves him maimed almost
beyond recognition
and leiter's physical
degeneration which is made shockingly
clear to readers in the next novel
diamonds of forever in 1956 stanza i
would argue as the sort of perfect uh
bodily metaname or metaphor for mi6 is
fictional elevation above the cia
whereas bond the briton appears
impeccably a tired athletic and
radiating sex appeal lighter the
american now uses crutches walks with a
limp and wears a prosthetic hook
now the implication that britain was the
professional intelligence service when
compared to
its american allies was given its
clearest articulation in from russia
with love which came out in 1957
at the start of the novel we learned
that the kgb quote is plotting to strike
at the heart of the intelligence
apparatus of the west unquote and the
kgb reaches the conclusion that it
should be an attack on mi6 not the cia
which should be their top priority since
they believe that mi6 best incarnates
the strength of western intelligence and
their assessment reads their agents are
good they pay them little money but they
serve with devotion they are rarely
awarded a decoration until they retire
and yet these men and women continue to
do this dangerous work it is curious it
is perhaps the public school and
university tradition the love of
adventure
by contrast the cia is viewed by the kgb
as somewhat second rate
according to the the the assessment that
the the the kgb make the cia lacked a
sort of kipling-esque love of the game
for its own sake was only really capable
of getting intelligence and particularly
recruiting agents or assets by offering
them vast sums of money
now i would argue that fleming's
depiction of mi6 is sort of superior to
the cia both in terms of its
intelligence gathering abilities and
also its passion for the great game of
espionage is a little flawed it doesn't
quite stand up to closer scrutiny in the
mid to late 1950s mi6 had to endure some
truly awful embarrassing moments moments
that that seeped out into the public
domain
the so-called buster crab affair in 1956
made mi6 out to be clumsy and
amateurish
crab affair concerned the mysterious
disappearance of frogman lionel buster
crabb coaxed out of retirement by mi6 to
investigate the hull of the russian
cruiser or johnny kidsey docked in
portsmouth harbour as part of a state
visit of khrushchev and bulgarnin
as recently published articles on the
subject have shown mi6 had no right to
sanction the dive
keen to build bridges with the soviet
union the prime minister anthony eden
had expressly forbidden the operation
under no circumstances was this
operation to go ahead but mi6 did it
anyway
mi6 i think should never have recruited
crap by then in his 50s
hopelessly unfit and i won't go into any
more details about this uh but some i i
i would argue he was the first sort of
scuba fetishist uh he had he had a lot
of strange peccadillos that really made
him quite inappropriate for this
operation um but the crab affair also
showed mi6 to be unprincipled when
crab's disappearance leaked out into the
public domain mi6 basically attempted to
conceal
the details of this botched operation by
making the admiralty the full guy
instead of coming clean it asked the
admiralty to issue a spurious statement
a false statement saying that crab was
actually working for them and he was
testing
new equipment uh in in the harbor in
real life i think the cia was no less
professional than mi6 many retired cia
officers have since written memoirs
pointing out contra fleming that the 50s
marked a time when the sort of love of
the game for its own sake was at its
peak
according to the memoir of dwayne dewey
claridge who joined the cia in 1955 many
people in the agency at this time just
couldn't wait to get up in the morning
and get to work so enamored were they
with the magic and mystery of espionage
and fleming suggested him from russia
with love that the cia could only
recruit assets by promising them
handsome remunerative benefits i think
was also overstated in the early years
of the cold war shows clearage quite
convincingly cia case officers realized
quite quickly that fee for service
recruitment seldom produced satisfactory
results uh and accordingly they
developed other means of acquiring their
targets
to my uh to my final subsection which
i've called a meeting of mines
now fleming's spy stories won a number
of high profile admirers the kennedy
family including brothers jack and
roberts were ardent devotees
in an article for life magazine in 1961
president kennedy famously named from
russia with love as one of his 10
favorite books but among the most
interesting i think of bond aficionados
was the gentleman here
to the right cia director alan dulles to
the dismay of more serious spy fiction
writers people like john le carre and
graham greene
dulles had a full set of fleming's
thrillers in his library rhapsodized
about double 07's adventures in the in
in the press and even attended
screenings of the films
for dulles
to be such a strong admirer of bond is i
think pretty surprising historically
intelligence practitioners are quite
keen to distance themselves from this
sort of gun-toting popular hero mocking
him as nothing more than sort of cheap
literature read on trains or in the
airport departure lounge as dulles
himself once recollected many of the
professionals working for me in the cia
never could quite understand this
weakness of the boss
now one can only surmise why
dulles liked fleming and liked the
bondian formula
i think that that dulles saw a lot of
himself in the fictional secret agent
and with good reason
like double 07 he held a sort of
manichaean view of the world as a a as a
sort of morality play between good and
evil both dulles and bond possessed a
visceral conviction that soviet
communism was a threat to the security
of the west
like 007 dulles was a romantic breed of
intelligence officer indeed he even died
with a copy of kipling's kim by his
bedside table unlike 007 moreover dulles
was something of a casanova besides his
long-suffering wife clover his sexual
conquests included the queen of greece
no less so accordingly when dulles
passed away on the 29th of january 1969
many obituaries ran with the headline
america's james
bond whatever the reason for dulles
fascination with double 07 by the late
1950s he basically made it his mission
to meet fleming in person and the two
men met for the first time in london in
1959 at a function arranged by members
of mi6 and here fleming held everybody's
spellbound with his views on the future
of intelligence where would it be in the
next 10 years where would it be in the
next 20 years and fleming in particular
spoke at length about the role that
technology would play in the future
dulles you know he wanted to sort of
stand up for his his agency well he he
responded by speaking passionately about
the cia's successes in the field of
overhead reconnaissance most notably the
suprasecret u2 spy plane at the time
being used to overfly the soviet union
cuba and the middle east but fleming was
unimpressed as he saw it the cia was not
doing enough in the area of special
devices gadgets and gizmos
fleming went on to explain that many of
bond's ingenious gadgets have been
inspired by real equipment he had seen
devised by british scientists during the
second world war
according to fleming bond's
quartermaster q was in fact based on a
real person a certain charles fraser
smith
working secretly out of a small office
near saint james's park in london fraser
smith had been employed by the ministry
of supply to make gizmos for agents uh
soe special operations uh executive
agents operating
in occupied france and some of fraser
smith's most unforgettable bits of kit
included a steel
shoelace that doubled as a garage and a
golf ball that contained a compass and
actually the latter famously appeared in
the novel diamonds are forever
with a sort of strange boyish enthusiasm
dulles flew back to langley and
immediately tasked cia engineers with
replicating as many of bond's devices as
they could
speaking to life magazine in august 1964
dulles reported that the cia had
successfully managed to um just go back
there
to reproduce rosa clebs infamous
assassination tool a spring-loaded
poison knife shoe which you see at the
end of from russia with love when rosa
clem tries to kick out at bond cia
scientists had less luck trying to
replicate automobile technology dulles
was particularly eager for the cia to
develop the homing beacon which we see
in goldfinger which could be fitted to a
car and used to track its whereabouts
this is dulles i put my people in cia to
work on this as a serious project
but they came up with the answer that it
had too many bugs in it the car device
really didn't work very well when the
enemy got into a crowded city
now dallas was due to see fleming again
on the 13th of march 1960 at a dinner
party held by the kennedy family at
their home in georgetown and this
episode is is is well reported in the
literature it's got a bit of a legendary
status for intelligence historians like
myself but it's worth repeating it's a
marvelous little little episode the
guest list for the evening was
distinguished it included painter
william walton newspaper columnist joe
ulsop and high-ranking cia official john
bross now when uh when at the last
minute dulles sadly was called away on
other business he basically left
instructions with bros to report back on
what transpired that evening and after a
few pleasantries
basically conversation turned to
espionage they were probably quite a bit
of alcohol had been consumed by this
point as well
kennedy probably only half in the spirit
of jest asked for fleming's advice on
how to topple fidel castro the cuban
leader who is a perennial thorn in the
side of the united states
as fleming saw it it was not simply
enough to kill castro he had to be
humiliated
to do this fleming suggested flooding
the streets of havana with pamphlets
explaining that radioactive fallout from
u.s atomic testing caused impotence and
was known to be drawn to men who had
beards as a result
as a result cuban men would be forced to
shave off their facial hair thus
severing an important symbolic link to
castro and to the revolution now
needless to say everyone including the
president-elect burst into laughter but
there's an interesting postscript to
this story and that is that the next day
bros informed alice of fleming's madcap
schemes there are a couple of others as
well which i won't go into detail about
now fully expecting his superior to see
this as just sheer poppycock
to bros his astonishment dulles was
quite impressed by all this sort of
stuff and raced to the telephone to
speak to fleming uh sadly it is at this
point the paper trail runs cold
but it may just be coincidence and i'm
only spitballing here but of course
shortly thereafter the kennedy brothers
along with the agency implemented
operation mongoose a covert action
program aimed at stimulating a rebellion
in cuba
overseen by major general edward
lansdale mongos authorized a number of
fantastical bondin-esque plots against
castro
in the church committee hearings and in
subsequent investigations it came out
that the cia had seriously looked into
hiring the mafia to do a contract
killing uh
famously the the the the you know offing
him with an exploding cigar that's
talked about there's even talk about um
the agency contaminating castro's
frogman suit with madura foot a fatal
tropical disease now although there is
no direct evidence to suggest that
fleming had been consulted by dulles to
help develop a final solution to the
castro problem it is pretty tempting it
is nevertheless incredibly tempting to
suggest that the author had played a
part in encouraging the cia down the
path of fantasy
now dulles and fleming remained close
friends until the spy writer's death on
the 12th of august 1964.
fleming gave dulles signed copies of all
his novels
in return dulles sent the author an
early draft of his memoir the craft of
intelligence and in doing so dulles
blindly disregarded the rule that
intelligence officers should not
disseminate their writings outside of
the cia until it has been reproved uh
approved and vetted for
for public release
and the key point is actually dulles
special acquaintance with fleming
actually brought benefits to the cia's
public profile
out of respect for his american friend
fleming generously agreed to include in
his later novels an increasing number of
glowing references to the cia
and nowhere was this more apparent than
in thunderball published in march 1961
when bond is assigned to the bahamas to
recover two missing atomic bombs his
boss m speaks enthusiastically about way
about the way the agency was selfly
putting itself in the service of freedom
we've teamed up with the cia to cover
the world said m alan dulles even
mentioning dulles by name here is
putting every man he's got on it and so
am i
later in the novel bond even states
that he has quote no false pride unquote
in admitting that the cia can do certain
things better than mi6
in the man with the golden gun bond
recover recovers from his jewel with the
villain scaramanga by quote sitting in
his chair a towel round his waist
reading alan allen dulles's the craft of
intelligence unquote and i think it is
as hard to it
it is hard to escape the notion that
fleming and dulles came to
came close to what academics i think
would now refer to as a citation ring
they're permanently talking about each
other
to my uh to my conclusion which i've
sort of tentatively called the cia and
the sort of slow embracing of popular
culture
in the 50s and early 60s ian fleming a
british fiction writer introduced
millions of people to the cia
his novels were published in a period
when the agency adhered to a doctrine of
near total secrecy and when cia activity
had really yet to appear in the writings
of journalists and historians
at the time the cia was largely absent
from popular culture with hollywood on
the one hand fearful of reprisals from
the state for failure to play by the
rules and on the other hand sympathetic
to the agency's need for secrecy in a
tense cold war environment and the net
result was that fleming remarkably
enjoyed something of a cultural monopoly
when it came to what people read about
the agency and in the main his portrayal
was pretty positive through the
character of felix lighter a romana clef
of u.s trailblazer william donovan cia
officials were shown to be talented and
dedicated patriots doing job
with high risk and little reward
fleming presented readers with a
remorselessly upbeat and evangelical
portrayal of cia's relationship with mi6
whereas in real life there was bickering
and distrust between the two services
the bond saga stressed harmony and the
powerful influence of cultural affinity
when fleming became good friends with
dulles this positive depiction took on
even more of a personal edge with the
author even including direct references
to the retired cia chief in the novel
there is nevertheless a clear
implication in the novels that the
agency at this time still had a lot to
learn about the trade craft of
intelligence double 07 is both a
supplicant and a teacher to the
well-heeled but inexperienced lighter
in the period in which fleming was
writing it is striking that unlike other
federal government departments the fbi
the pentagon the department of defense
the agency made no concerted effort to
engage with mass consumption cultural
outlets in order to promote its public
profile
the relationship between dulles and
fleming was very much the exception
rather than the rule and in a way this
was not surprising the agency at the
time led a mostly untroubled sub rosa
existence and saw no reason to spoil a
good thing moreover fleming's populist
portrayal was hardly unedifying
by the mid 80s however the climate had
changed and the cia began to reassess
its policy of detachment from culture
in the 70s grim revelations about cia
dirty dealings were the catalyst for an
explosion of what i would call counter
culture cia stories far removed from the
benign fleming formula the jason bourne
novels of robert ludlum suggested that
the agency had lethal assassins roaming
the world
from hollywood films like three days of
the condor and marathon man built up a
picture of the agency as a group of sort
of pitiless machiavellian schemers
operating with minimal oversight and a
predilection for bribery brainwashing
and brute force
ugly revelations amplified and distorted
at the hands of novelists and filmmakers
convinced a new generation of
intelligence officers that the cia had
an image problem and that popular
culture could help
forward-thinking individuals i i can't
name them at this point made the case
that films and novels had to be taken
seriously by the cia since they had a
real if intangible impact upon way the
age upon the way the agency was
perceived by the public in an ideal
world popular attitudes towards
intelligence services should not be
conditioned by popular culture but sadly
the world is not ideal in the words of
john mclaughlin a former deputy director
of the cia public perceptions quote
depend to a large extent on what the
audience see in cinematic documentary
and novelistic sources unquote
recognizing that popular culture had a
powerful social utility from the 80s
onwards the cia started to reach out i
think to sympathetic novelists and
filmmakers under the banner of what it
called institutional advertising and
initially links with purveyors of
fiction were kept pretty informal much
in the same way that dulles cultivated a
very cozy private relationship with
fleming in 1984 and then again a few
years later the agency invited the
best-selling author tom clancy to spend
a day at langley
by the mid-90s links became more
formalized with the agency even setting
up an entertainment liaison office whose
job was and remains to assist filmmakers
and authors in the production of
storylines and famously the liaison
office worked closely with the makers of
the cbs television drama the agency
ensuring that scripts were a fair and
accurate reflection of cia work in
return cbs was granted unprecedented
access to cia props locations and was
even allowed to shoot certain
scenes at langley
in one famous episode the cia's mission
is remarkably to save the life of
long-time nemesis fidel castro
as this lecture has hopefully shown
although dulles might well have raised
an eyebrow at this particular storyline
it is fairly certain that he would have
supported the broader policy of trying
to use fiction to shape popular
understanding thank you very much
[Applause]
um
we have time for a few questions
absolutely
delight delighted to take to take
questions
hi there hi i'm um from indiana
university and i believe that we have
mostly ian plumbing differences
uh i i i've been through the collection
that marvel's little collection
but you're not uh
you're not not a phd student that i
recently got to go back and do some
additional research
okay
but um
did you find particular things um that
happened during the
editing process i seem to remember that
he had a fairly uh
active editor right
sorry did he have a fairly active editor
even
yeah uh for the for the bomb novels um
yeah i mean
i mean in truth i didn't see didn't see
a great a great deal of evidence of that
but
question in case it is
according to the gentleman here uh some
of the papers from from indiana
university admittedly i don't think i've
consulted the same ones uh you were
saying that fleming had a very active
editor you suggesting possibly that that
the it was the editor and not fleming
itself that was rail ratings railroading
some of the narrative uh i just haven't
seen those those particular documents
sadly um
but
[Music]
yeah i mean it's mainly um
it's mainly i mean if you take the
fleming papers at indiana and then you
take the dulles papers at princeton uh
you actually get to see the
correspondence that are going back and
forth from dulles to fleming uh there's
a lot of you know what we might think as
as trivial or tangential stuff you know
merry christmas uh hope you had a nice a
nice birthday but what i think is is
striking there is that these two men
just got on very well as friends they
got on extremely well as friends they
always address each other as alan and
ian and i just think it's quite telling
that we have this meeting where dulles
and fleming meet in in 1959 and this is
really arranged by members of mi6 i mean
fleming has been out of the intelligence
world for the best part of 14 15 years
at this point and yet he's still somehow
plugged into the intelligence community
i find that absolutely fascinating but
in terms of some of the other material
that you'll get
in the fleming papers fleming is also
liaising with a whole
host of other quite interesting
individuals in fact there's
there's a i don't know how much uh is is
known about this but there's there's an
extraordinary correspondence um sent to
fleming by
uh hugh gateskill who was then the uh
the the the labour party leader
uh and he's saying dear ian again they
always address each other in first name
terms de ian ah
i'm greatly fond of bond i love the
novels you know i must come and see you
at some point he neglected to mention
the fact that he was actually having a
having an affair with fleming's wife
lady anne rothermere at this point so i
find that uh i find that quite telling
uh as it comes to my mind actually
there's a there's another
lovely um correspondence between dulles
and fleming
fleming's spirits are low
at this point we're talking i think 1963
and
fleming has just finished writing on her
majesty's secret service which actually
concludes with with bond seemingly
contemplating retirement it seems
following the drive-by shooting of his
new wife trace tracy d'angelo whatever
her name is and dulles actually sends
fleming a lovely letter and he says dear
ian i do hope you haven't seriously
considered quote pensioning off
my uh
my my friend i think he refers to him as
my friend double07 uh and again one can
only speculate here you know you're
making it big intuitive leaf but one
might speculate that uh
dulles
intervention there uh might have gone a
little way to persuading fleming to
write uh some some subsequent novels
hi there
interesting talk we very much enjoyed it
just a question uh in reality i guess um
the cra was much better equipped and
more resources was perhaps even more
professional than mi6 in the 50s and 60s
if that is correct did mr6 try to use
fleming to obtain a better relationship
with the cia to obtain information
rather than the other way around sadly i
mean i i i pride myself on on having um
an encyclopedic knowledge almost of
intelligence collections and getting to
as many
archives as i can there is no direct
evidence whatsoever that fleming was was
somehow
still in league with mi6
the mi6 was somehow using him to
to cozy up to the agency there's no
there's no evidence in that sense what
we're seeing here is a very informal
relationship between um between the two
men um
but sadly there's there's there's no
greater evidence of that um fleming may
also
again i'm just spitballing here he may
also have had a little bit of of of a
private agenda um in the 50s and 60s he
was very keen
for there to be an official history of
british intelligence during the second
world war
ah the larger work eventually came out
in 1979 and and there were there were
subsequent volumes uh edited by by the
cambridge historian harry hinsley uh
that came out in in the 90s eventually
but fleming was actually very keen and
he was pressing the point to a number of
old hands in british intelligence during
the second world war including a chat
called uh vice admiral sir norman
denning who later went on to become the
chairman of the d notice committee
basically fleming wanted to write
a public unclassified official history
of british intelligence services and i
think dulles might have dropped
somewhere into conversation that under
dulles watch the agency had sponsored a
gentleman called whitney shepherdson
to begin writing an official history of
oss office of strategic services this
thing never came out but i think fleming
was perhaps
seeing what the americans were doing in
the area of public engagement and hoping
potentially to become the author of that
volume
himself but it never got off the ground
it never got off the ground and it
wasn't really until
the mid late 1960s when fleming uh when
it was it was denning actually it was
stanning um started to encourage old
veterans in the british intelligence
community to publish memoirs people like
john masterman the double cross
committee people like frederick
winterbottom to release the ultra secret
all of these memoirs started coming out
in the late 60s early 1970s for a
a public relations purpose essentially
at the time you had the nasty kim philby
revelations coming out in the late 1960s
revealing the secrets of bletchley park
an enigma the ultra secret was seen as a
good way to counterblast these damaging
revelations and restore some of the
pride uh
in in the british intelligence community
after the bloody nose of of the
cambridge five revelations
oh my word they've all they've all
sprung up now uh should we take the
gentleman at the back
quick observation of the fact that you
didn't see any evidence of mi6 efforts
to use
may just be a reflection of the program
of course my real question is what
resources here at the library of
congress have you been using sure uh the
the main one for me has been david atlee
phillips uh there is some truly
wonderful material in there there's i
think five or six boxes that i've taken
that i've taken photographs of the
phillips collection is is extraordinary
he was just a voracious collector of
intelligence literature and all sorts of
miscellaneous uh the sheer number of
press clippings that you see in this
collection are extraordinary the amount
of correspondence that he's having
people having with people are
mind-boggling he's kept a very good
paper trail that we can follow up there
so david atlee phillips is is very good
uh again i'm plugging the collections
here at the library of congress called
meyer another um agency uh veteran and
ray klein
ray klein so we have three or four major
collections of cia officers that that
are quite large uh
and we in in a way i've been doing what
an intelligence officer does which is
searching for nuggets of information and
trying to piece them together but uh the
david atley phillips one in particular
is is fascinating uh a lied to one or
two others around the united states
hi there
specifically in your presentation how
certain
characters were based off real people
like you
did you find any other evidence that
yeah
sure
the famous one is um
is and and fleming actually
uh
says this in in one of the
correspondence that i've seen and this
has also been reported in some of the
various fleming biographies that have
been written by people like andrew
lysett but the famous example is m
bonds uh very avuncular
on some occasions quite cold snappy boss
is said to be
a roman a clef of admiral john godfrey
who was head of british naval
intelligence during the second world war
fleming is said to have modeled model m
on on godfrey um but even bond is is
said to be a sort of there are
suggestions he's that he's a sort of
hybrid character of several soes special
operations executive agents that fleming
had uh had seen uh during during the
second world war um but there's there's
also little subtle hints i mean that the
british
uh in 1945 1946
started writing uh classified in-house
official histories of some aspects of
the intelligence work during the second
world war and what's fascinating is that
fleming i've discovered actually had
access to some of these um you know
hundred page secret documents so what's
fleming reading these for is it for
historical purposes is it out of
personal interest or is he perhaps as
you're hinting drawing upon these
official narratives to construct a more
convincing piece of fiction i think
there's some some very interesting work
to be done in that area the the the the
one work that i know that um
teases out the
the inspiration quite well for
fleming's characters is a book by ben
mcintyre uh and it's called for their
eyes only i think ian fleming and james
bond that's the one you want to go to
hi there sir
you mentioned towards the end of your
talk how you know by the late 60s early
70s the cio's appearing a whole lot more
in movies but that typically these
portrayals were not overly complimentary
and you mentioned among other things uh
three days at the condor and yet early
on you had this remarkable photograph
yeah richard helms apparently on set uh
with robert redford i'm curious
i'm attached to um
quite a large ah uk government-funded
project uh back home in the cia
back home in the cia back home in the
united back home in back home
freudian slip uh back home in the uk
this photograph baffles us this
absolutely baffles us because as as as
you point out and as i pointed out three
days of a condor is pretty savage
towards the agency and yet we have a
remarkable photograph of cia director
richard helms uh in deep conversation
there with robert redford uh what went
wrong what went wrong uh i haven't
managed to put my finger on it i mean
the only other example of that is
there was a film that came out a few
years ago
that cia official historians in
particular in their open journal studies
of intelligence have absolutely trashed
a film called the good shepherd
absolutely trashed it uh
directed by robert de niro got all sorts
of spurious allegations and it's it's
got the it's the machiavellian schemers
uh picture that you get from that but
what's striking is that um
a lot of old oss hands were actually
brought in as historical consultants for
this film in fact i have it on authority
that um
once the film was made
a lot of these old oss hands were
invited to a film screening by robert de
niro at the four seasons hotel in
georgetown and they all sat there you
know delighted all we've got you know
we've got a fair and accurate historical
representation of the good work that we
did in the second world war and in the
early years of the cold war and within
about 10 minutes 80 percent of the
audience have either got up started
shouting profanities or left
uh
de niro the filmmaker his impulse to
dramatize to sensationalize led him to
take the uh the advice and information
that uh that he got from these these
veterans um
but but the final release completely
distorted the historical picture um so i
think something might also have happened
uh there with uh with three days of a
condor
hi there sir hi i'm talking about uh
getting the cia right or getting the cia
wrong
is fascinating uh what do you think
about the uh film and book charlie
wilson's war charlie wilson's has a lot
to say about this guy
i haven't seen the film i'm led to
believe it stars tom hanks is that
correct and i and um
i haven't i haven't read the uh the book
but um
no i just i just not not in a position
to comment on that having not seen or
read either of the two mediums i do
apologize
hi there
i'm wondering if the female characters
in the books
are similar to the characters in the
films
and if so have you identified any of
these women
who
are portrayed in the
films as
a bit extraordinary
i mean one i'll i'll just add a a little
point to that um
the
you know the novels are quite sexist
let's let's not beat around the bush
here this is this is 1950s this is a
hard cold warrior like fleming who's uh
who's who's in his element talking about
scantily clad women and such forth um
what's fascinating if you go to the
production code
files uh for the james bond films that
are held at impasse the academy of
motion picture arts and sound sciences
in beverly hills los angeles you get the
production code files on the early bond
films so dr no from russia with love
goldfinger
the early drafts were i mean the bond
films are pretty sexist in the 1960s but
what is absolutely extraordinary is the
early early drafts were even more sexist
there was going to be harsh language
there was actually going to be
shots of of open clip i feel very
uncomfortable talking about this in a
way but but we'll run with it we'll run
with it uh open shots of of cleavage and
such forth uh bond being incredibly
crude incredibly crude in his dealings
with uh with some of the uh the the the
women in the series and the production
code stops it they said no no no you
know we haven't yet got around to ladies
chat lady chatterley's lover you know
this is just beyond the pale we cannot
go this far so while on the one hand
scholars are always saying my word the
bomb the films in the 60s are incredibly
sexist they're misogynist bond as a
dinosaur etc etc
crikey it was only a last-minute
intervention intervention by the
production code that prevented
something you know like a scene out of
eyes wide shut or or a kubrick uh
interpretation so there we are that's
all i can add on that one i think
chris i hate to break this up because
i'm sure there's a lot more questions
that they're going to have we're going
to have to call an official vault
very
absolutely
[Music]
wonderful
[Music]
coming up on the civil war the fort
sumter fort moultrie has